well joining me now to discuss more on
what's happening on the ground in
Ukraine is defense and security analysts
Professor Michael Clarke good afternoon
to you so more attacks then overnight
Michael what can you tell us about them
yes I mean more attacks on Ukraine again
some deaths in Kiev what was interesting
last night from a military point of view
is that some of these attacks were
carried out by ballistic missiles his
scandal missiles which the Russians
fired from
um from the Northeast part of Russia on
that part of the border and the
ukrainians there they shot all of them
down all 10 of them now normally there's
no defense against ballistic missiles
they're just too difficult to defend
against with what the ukrainians have
had but now they've got Patriot missiles
and so it looks like the American
Patriots are working very well in
Ukrainian hands against ballistic
missiles they claim they shot all 10
down I think that's probably true
otherwise we'd see more evidence of them
if any of them have got through so
although it was another night of
attacking Kiev the ukrainians did pretty
well and it shows that the the Patriot
batteries are a problem for the Russians
if they're going to keep this up
meanwhile uh there is more fighting over
the border now in the Belgrade area in
the shabinka uh shibakino in particular
today
um the groups of these militias these
Russian national militias who fight for
Ukraine they're Irregulars so there's
the uh Russia volunteer Corps as they
call themselves and the freedom for
Russia Legion and they seem to have gone
over the Border again for the second
time in about 10 days and they've
attacked this Administrative Building in
shabbatino and they look as if they've
put a series of probably grad Rockets
onto the roof I mean the way those fires
have broken out it rather looks as if a
flight of rockets has hit the roof which
won't destroy the building but it
certainly uh damaged it and it's pretty
Visual and so and that is the
administrative building because you can
see all the Russian Flags in the
foregrounds that car whipped past them
and reportedly there is now fighting in
Belgrade itself in the city of Belgard
um we don't know we haven't got that
confirmed we don't know how serious it
is but it's certainly a lot of a certain
amount of panic and Russian border
forces is and troops are engaged it
seems with these militias who are again
for the second time over the Border
um I suspect that they'll they would
draw pretty quickly this evening leaving
behind uh quite a lot of evidence of yet
another incursion and fighting on the
border area what about within Ukraine
itself what's happening on the front
line there on the front line This is
interesting we've been following this
for a few days now the Russians are
they've put the Wagner Fighters are
coming out of back mode between now and
the end of this week really the fifth
fourth and fifth of June they say
they're going to be out of back mode and
they're being replaced by other forces
but the forces that the Russians are
putting into back much to replace them
are these Irregulars uh these volunteer
battalions and now we hear that the
chechens kadirovs chechens are going
into bakman to take up those positions
now the chechens again there's not many
of them there's only about seven
thousand at most and they're not really
particularly good Fighters they're not
they're not good at sort of going
forward in a conventional sense so again
that tells me that the Russians don't
expect to have to do any more fighting
your back mood because they own it now
and it's strategically fairly
unimportant it always was however a
criminal in the north and at uh of
diffka at marinka and vuladar in the
South that's where the Strategic
importantly important areas are and I
think if we do see fighting in the
donbass soon we don't know if we will
but if we just if we see this offensive
beginning in the dombas it'll almost
certainly be north and south of bakmud
and that seems to be what the Russians
think when we look at the sort of forces
that they're deploying there that's so
interesting and meanwhile diplomatically
there's a big meeting going on in
Moldova at the moment isn't there all
the European leaders meeting there
president zorenski is there so what's
your take on that meeting yeah it's a
huge media and the British prime
ministers there as well they're all gone
there's 47 governments represented
everyone but Russia and Belarus are
represented there including the EU
Moldova is the second poorest country in
Europe it's very small tiny little
Enclave used to be part of Romania and
it's three million people and uh about
half a million or about three million
people are Russian sep artists and they
occupy what the what this self-declared
transistorian Republic and this is a
republic on the Eastern side of the
Nisha River there was a civil war there
in 1992 and so this area this is sort of
a sliver here uh east of the Nisha River
and this area they call themselves a
transition Republic there are 1500
Russian troops in that area supposedly
peacekeepers and the United Nations has
twice told them they're illegitimate can
get out the Russians just ignore it and
so the Russians have got troops there
and we all thought when this battle
started when the when the Russians got
west of Nikolai which we thought they
would do get towards a desk so they keep
on going they'd link up with transnetra
and Moldova would would collapse as a
state it would collapse into Civil War
fall into the Russian orbit it hasn't
happened Maria Maya Sandu who's the
Prime Minister very tough prime minister
there she is in the middle in the green
hosting this great diplomatic Jamboree
she's done incredibly well elected in
2020 she's stood up to Putin she's a
really tough cookie and out of the
weakest state in Europe she has helped
to manufacture with zelinski there a
sort of diplomatic Triumph and so this
whole European security Community are
discussing All European issues but
they're doing it in Moldova and this is
a sign of the support that they feel
they want to give to Moldova we thought
it wouldn't Exist by now but they're
doing all right fascinating absolutely
fascinating Michael as ever thanks very
much indeed